merci d'être avec nous en direct sur
herbst et france première question est
ce que ces enlèvements par des gangs
ils sont monnaies courantes haïti
bonsoir
stéphanie de mots effectivement c'est ça
fait 20 ans que l'industrie de l'
enlèvement fonctionne en haïti je suis
obligé de dire l'industrie de la vente
l'enlèvement parce que c'est devenu une
vanne une banalité alors avec des
périodes plus ou moins intense mais
aujourd'hui l'intensité accrue et au
point de s'en prendre à des gens
d'église et surtout ce qui était
exceptionnel exceptionnel c'est qu'on
s'en prenne à des étrangers
la première la première réflexion que ça
m'inspire c'est de vous dire que d'après
des en s'en prenant à l'étranger aux
étrangers ce sera peut-être peut-être
hélas a souhaité que ce sera la manche
d'une solution que la communauté
internationale prenne conscience de ce
qui se passe en haïti et peut-être que
ça mènera des réactions je n'en sais
rien pour l'instant je me contente de
vous dire ça la précision que je peux
vous apporter concernant les aînés
d'enlèvement c'est que ce week-end en 24
heures il ya eu près d'une douzaine dans
l'enlèvement en plus à faire au total en
comptant ce que vous venez de citer
et parmi les six autres six ou sept
autres en étant l'événement qui a eu
lieu celui d'un médecin chirurgien
orthopédiste celui d'un ancien grand
maître d'une grande loge de la grande
loge d'haïti du grand orient de france
est bref et un certain nombre d'autres
personnes de la famille des personnes
qui ont été les sept personnes qui a été
enlevé voilà c'est ça il dit c'est ce
qui est en train de se passer de façon
dramatique qui ce n'est pas
une thèse religieuse un crime religieux
c'est un truc crime crapuleux il demande
je le rappelle un million de dollars de
rançons sont nés dans un van du
crapuleux et rien à voir avec des scies
de catholiques en particulier comme vous
dites au nez d'un du crapuleux
n'importe qui peut être enlevé quel que
soit son statut
récemment j'ai des amis qui ont été
enlevées qui hélas qui heureusement s'en
sont bien tirés
il y a quelques années même presque
vingt ans j'ai quelqu'un de ma famille
qui a été enlevé et qui depuis grâce à
la lente reprise dans laquelle elle
travaillait sa rançon a été payée et la
quitter haïti
voilà ce qui est en train de se passer
et donc c'est ça aura certaines
conséquences j'ai envie de dire c'est
affreux j'ai envie de dire que ça aura
certaines conséquences heureusement
j'espère que la communauté
internationale j'insiste comprennent que
la situation est très grave parce que si
vous voulez le la première chose que
cela peut entraîner va certainement
entraîner c'est qu'il ya une fuite des
ressortissants haïtiens qui quittent le
pays
et comment vont ils essayer de quitter
le pays parce qu'on appelle les boat
people c'est à dire s'embarquer prendre
en gal s'engager sur des embarcations de
fortune
vous essayez de gagner les bahamas ou la
côte d'olaf la côte-d les côtes de
floride est peut-être là il y aura
vraiment une prise de conscience en ce
qui concerne ce gros drames humains que
vous constituez les boat people et
surtout là je me tourne vers les états
unis
parce que les états unis prendront
conscience que si leurs côtes sont nuit
ils sont utilisés comme lieu d'asile par
les uns et par les haïtiens même s'il
l'est refouleront mais vous n'avez
peut-être pas connu ces événements en
1994 après le coup d'état du général
c'est drass contre le président aristide
les haïtiens ont quitté en masse par les
boat people il ya eu des haïtiens venir
mourir sur les côtes de la floride ça a
poussé les états unis à réagir ou
destituer les dictateurs en place voilà
peut-être
voilà pourquoi je me permets de dire
qu'il ya peut-être une ébauche de prise
de conscience
évidemment ce n'est pas une solution que
l'on souhaite mais que voulez vous qu'on
fasse aujourd'hui comprendre c'est qu'en
fait le fait que ces banques soient de
plus en plus puissants c'est qu'ils sont
souvent soutenus pour certains par les
politiques eux mêmes soutenus par les
politiques même et surtout que la police
est infesté et corrompu et que la police
n'est pas motivée pour intervenir et
qu'au sein même de la police
il ya des gens qui renseigne les gangs
parce que c'est une question de
corruption tout bêtement j'ai envie de
lui je dis tout bêtement mais c'est
quand même dramatique la police
intervient sans conviction et au sein
même de la police il ya des espions au
service de ces gangs puisque ces gangs
paye
vous avez dit le montant de la rançon un
million de dollars entre autres il ya eu
d'autres sommes peut-être pas équivalent
de ce montant là mais qui ont été payées
et à chaque fois vous vous doutez bien
que ça a été distribué redistribuées
donc tout le monde a été pardon arrosé
un peu ce qui devait l'être
ça pose la question justement faut-il
payer ces rançons c'est toujours délicat
comme comme question là je n'ai pas la
réponse malheureusement je n'ai pas la
réponse
ce que j'ai envie de vous dire c'est en
ce qui concerne les étrangers les russes
en l'occurrence des ressortissants
français
à mon avis à mon avis mais je je dis
peut-être il ya peu de chances qu'on
attend à leur vie parce qu'ils savent
que si les gangs savent que s'ils s'en
prennent aux ressortissants étrangers
la conséquence peut être beaucoup plus
lourde pour eux parce que la dépression
peuvent être faits sur le surprenne
peuvent être faites sur le gouvernement
sous les gens en place
donc voilà c'est c'est difficile de
répondre
moi je ne vais pas mettre dans la
position d'un leader d'un lecteur de
polars qui va vous répondre
il faut pas céder il faut pas payer je
n'en sais rien je n'en sais rien
l'important pour les gens c'est de
sauver la vie c'est de sauver la vie de
leurs proches donc payer ou pas c'est ce
qu' il s'est lassé il faudra aller aller
vers une solution surtout qu'on récupère
les otages
en pleine vie merci beaucoup
jacquin ans émile d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur arte france